[Music]  your diary  I still haven't learned how to control  my inside voice but people actually like  what I have to say I've made so many new  friends and Corinne smiled at me again  today I have narrowed down our future  wedding songs to three options which one  of these you think I should wear to my  dear I said get out privacy come on you  do know that we can hear you writing in  your diary from every room in the house  right  mental note would I become president my  sister gets the lowest possible security  clearance Jeremy if you win you know  it's not just about popularity right  you'd have a real job to do I like the  blue bow that's when I go with that was  a girl yeah I didn't okay listen I'm  really excited for you and everything  but just remember that popularity  corrupts I could totally rock that bow